I come to you versus I go to him
and both of you guys are my uncle and
I'm his son okay hypothetically
so I go to Adam and I say Adam I gotta
tell you man I'm so sick of my dad Rob
it's just I'm so sick of it he wants me
to do this he wants me to do that he
wants me to eat this he wants me to
train like this he wants me to read this
book I'm so freaking tired of my dad
Adam says the following he says Ah your
dad's been annoying for his entire life
he's my brother I've known him he's
annoying just be patient when you're 18
get the hell away from him as quickly as
possible okay you shouldn't have to work
that hard that's not fair you're just a
kid why is he pushing you so hard that's
not what he should be doing a lot of
people disagree with your dad but
unfortunately there's nothing we can do
about it right now okay that's one uncle
now I go to his other brother it's you I
said Uncle Cal my dad is this my dad is
that he's so annoying and you say just
be lucky that's your dad okay because
he's raising a leader one day you're
gonna do this one day you're gonna do
that one are you gonna do this I would
be very grateful that you have the dad
that you have
there's two philosophies in America
right now one is feeling sorry for you
constantly the other one is telling you
step up and lead and do something about
it I like this more because it's keeping
less people dependent on a system this
is keeping more people dependent on the
system this mindset increases taxes this
mindset decreases taxes what are your
thoughts on that so first of all let me
just be clear I've never met a tax cut
for the working class that I didn't love
I love cutting taxes on Working Class
People so I'm not talking I'd give them
even more money right so what I'm
talking about is more on the topic you
know what I'm talking I'm talking about
contributing no I understand that let me
just address the point because I think
there's an important counter argument
which is
I don't think a system can justify
somebody working full-time and then they
don't get paid enough money to even
survive I think that system has failed
to prove itself as being the best system
to your point my in fact I almost agree
with your point maybe more than you do
because I want to reward the hard work
and my point is I feel like the hard
work is not being rewarded right now
because I think like I think like
basically 95 of the country is trying
their hardest and in many instances just
treading water in the same place and not
getting I don't know if it's 95 but but
I think majority are I don't think so we
have broad agreement on that yes yeah no
I do but but here here's the part so
when you're talking about you know uh uh
if a person's working a full-time job
and they're not able to pay the bills I
don't think that's fair okay fine no no
you're saying that no no no no I'm not
agreeing oh look we've made it I'm not
agreeing but this is now you know what I
would say here's what I would say sure
okay here's what I would say to them
uh there was a time my market value was
375 an hour and they probably overpaid
you know when they were paying me 375 an
hour because I was not a good employee
okay there was a time my market value
was six bucks an hour okay when I worked
at Burger King I was 475 an hour okay
when I worked at Valley Total Fitness it
was 720 an hour that's what they paid me
that was the market value for me because
the military paid me Pennies on a dollar
because the military you're working 100
hours a week so they're not paying you a
lot of money to make 800 bucks a month
you're broke
so when I'm sitting there at Bally's and
I'm making seven bucks an hour okay and
I'm broke and I can't do anything you
know what I would do on my break I
always had a book I read so I would sit
they would make fun of me I would sit
there and I'm reading a book I'm a 1.8
GPA guy okay I'm not a guy that's a
reading guy I'm a guy that started first
book I ever finished in my life cover to
cover I was 21 years old first book I
ever finished I was 21 years old so I'm
sitting there
and
on my break this guy named Jose who was
my boss he would come and make fun of me
you say Patrick what are you doing you
believe in this dream type of stuff of
being a millionaire do you realize I
make eighty thousand dollars a year I
drive a nice BMW I got a great life you
think these books are going to change
your life and I'm like listen man I have
no desire to make 80 000 because that's
a tough life for me I saw what my mom
and dad did I don't want to do what
you're doing you're clubbing five nights
a week you're on your third marriage I
just don't want that life and I told him
straight up he's like what so I don't
want your life it's that simple I just
don't want your life and I think there's
a lot of people that don't want that
life but rather than saying I think it's
unfair that these people are making only
this much and they can barely pay their
pay their bills my question to them is
what are you doing to increase your
market value if you increase your for
example you're using an iPhone right why
don't you use a Blackberry why don't you
use an old Nextel why don't you use a
Nokia why do you use a Blackberry why do
you use an iPhone it's pretty arbitrary
I just whatever phone fell in mind I
don't think that's the case though I
don't think that's the case things don't
even they're not really sold anymore
anyway some of them are some of the
shitty phones are still around but the
point is the following do you need that
phone because you need to check your
creative Studios you need to check
YouTube you need to get back on Twitter
yours your personality people want to
see what you have to say so that phone
has made the best argument to you as a
market value that's why you're using
that for not some of the older phones I
think the same way Apple has made the
argument to you to use their phone it's
the same way a lot of people need to sit
there and say well maybe my market value
is only forty two thousand dollars here
see I don't I don't disagree with you
though that's the thing I think we're
talking past each other because if your
argument is if I boil it down to its
simplest form if your argument is look
try your best don't stop trying learn
um keep reading keep expanding your
horizons don't take no for an answer uh
keep grinding if that's your message we
have total agreement because I see
nothing wrong with that at all in fact I
would also look I like to dabble every
now and then as well into the you know
listening to various self-help stuff
listen to a motivational rant sometimes
it gets me fired up sometimes I listen
I'm like let's let's [ __ ] go let's do
this thing so we don't disagree at all I
think the only area of disagreement we
have is that even if we had a society
where literally 100 of people did what
you're recommending there the problem is
that the system itself does not reward
that inherently so we could still have
10 million people living in abject
poverty and be working poor so they're
still trying but they still just get a
bad roll the dice and they don't get far
enough that's the thing that I'm focused
on in terms of the system and how to fix
it in terms of the individual you and I
have total agreement because of course I
I would give people I would give the
people in my life personally and you
know to my audience I'd give them the
exact same advice you just gave which is
and by the way how do you think I made
it on YouTube in the first place well
you think I'm just better than everybody
my personality is just like oh that guy
is so Dynamic
yeah I kept showing up right I kept
showing up I never stopped for the first
year and a half or two years I had
nobody's [ __ ] watching I had nobody
watching me there was probably less than
20 people with their eyeballs on me for
my show when I was doing a two or three
hour show every single day so yeah I
think we agree more than more than uh we
recognized I just I just think that
message we we collectively need to give
that message more because I think what
you've done okay let me ask you Kyle uh
uh if if a thousand people out there
want to do what Kyle's doing okay unless
you say out of these thousand people
they're paying their their interest is
not politics one guy's interest is
basketball right but very good like
follows everything to basketball one is
movies and it's a great movie critic
right one is food recipes one is you
know writing one is math well whatever
it is right everybody has something to
offer to the to society
do you think if they
apply themselves and work the way you
have and stay disciplined the way you
have you think they could also
eventually make it I think a certain
percentage of them but I think if I'm if
I'm guessing maybe
15 only 15 would make it if they did
what you did 20. well yeah well I think
it's very highly obviously what do you
say like for 400 people I said a
thousand people okay a thousand people
yeah I think look
the the harsh truth of the world how
many videos have you uploaded how many
videos have you uploaded
tens of thousands bro you're saying like
you're saying like what you've done is
easy all I'm saying to you is if anybody
goes out there how much material do you
read to stay on top to how Timeless from
when I wake up to when I go okay so if I
do yeah what you do in my space of
specialty I'm a Disney guy I'm a
business guy I'm a sports guy I'm a art
guy I'm a you know scam guy like I study
all the scams because there's great
YouTube channels that do I'm I'm a guy
that does what they do but if I study
the way you study and research and I put
10 000 videos on YouTube don't you think
I'm eventually gonna make it in my
specialty it's not a guarantee and
that's the that's the sad reality I
think that you disagree with that do you
disagree with that but but let me say
what I mean like okay so it's very hard
to debate this from your perspective
here's okay uh do you work out you're a
good looking guy I don't know I did for
quite a while okay now so I do the Trump
workout regimen because I play golf
Trump
okay so so let me ask you this let me
ask you this we got a thousand people
we're gonna play this game in a
different way we got a thousand people
if we have a thousand people who agreed
okay to stop eating bread stop eating
sugar okay and they got one cheat day a
month not even a week they got one cheat
month whatever you want per month but
for 29 days you're straight up clean
they did cardio three times a week 30
minutes and they went to the gym and
they did weights for 45 minutes four
times a week if a thousand people did it
they're all losing weight they're all
losing every single one of them Point
what I'm trying to say is if people
followed your methodology of researching
reading working ten thousand busting
their ass when no one's watching them
they're eventually going to win because
that's the that's how formulas work I
understand that I guess the core of our
disagreement though is how much can be
attributed to nurture slash environment
versus nature and I think the core of
our disagreement here is especially when
it comes to to this particular field of
YouTube we all know people let's keep it
real there are people who have
effectively anti-charisma sometimes P
there are some people who talk and you
go they have that X Factor I listen to
them and I'm like I want to listen to
every [ __ ] word they say and then
there's some people where the second
they open
yeah it's called a high tune-out fact
yeah we're familiar with that around
here one of the biggest YouTubes right
now blowing up is ran by a guy that has
no he's not a Charisma I get it look
he's not a Charisma no no but he's so
beyond he does have he does have his own
Charisma I'll disagree with you on that
because and I think Noam Chomsky too
agree or disagree with him he makes
monotone sounds I've had them on I've
had him on Lex makes uh monotone sound
good yeah yeah but I don't think
you know what's crazy like I've been in
sales for 21 years
what I used to judge as somebody that's
going to be a great salesperson I failed
miserably let me explain to you why so I
would see a guy I'm like oh my God this
guy's personality is freaking class this
guy's gonna blow up he's going to make
millions right officers like no he
didn't he was lazy and then I had a guy
that was a terrible accent from stage he
would say the key to success is you
gotta Focus
what you gotta [ __ ] do [ __ ] it for
success
by the way if he ever writes a book he's
got to write a book says the key is [ __ ]
is right
f-u-c-k-i-s but what he's trying to say
is you gotta Focus right yeah yeah yeah
and then he would go and talk to
families yeah half the time you would on
some but it wasn't like he was as
charismatic as the other guy but the guy
was willing to do the work all I'm
saying Kyle to you is the following all
I'm saying is I think
when people come up to me and they say
you know well you don't understand the
challenges and you don't understand the
life of you don't understand how hard it
is I like how many books have you read
in the last six months what course are
you taking to improve yourself what are
you doing to get better and if the
answer is no you know every yeah I have
a problem with that I I think that
person needs to be held accountable yeah
I agree I mean look I think the problem
is we're having two separate
conversations I think there's one
conversation about the system and how we
address the system then there's a whole
other conversation about at the
individual level how do you treat people
what values do you impart on them and I
think on the values front on the
individual front we agree 100 because
yeah you should focus you should try to
create a culture of hard work you should
try to create a culture of people
showing up being passionate about
something giving their all to something
uh it's just in my in my view it's just
two separate conversations where you
could also have a separate conversation
about what do we do with the system what
do we do with the tax rates what do we
do with the living wage law what do we
do about unions and so that's that's
where our disconnect is coming from so
with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bad toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]